and tell me this question together okay
I know a few you were doing it there's a
couple of things different there but one
is subtracting the middle pane number
two
yeah fraction over this side as well
okay now as you'll see that won't cause
too many troubles let's think about how
we did it before okay we multiply by
particularly but where did we get that
number from we looked at these two
numbers
yeah we wanted the lowest common
multiple of five a - in this case it's
ten okay now tens nice tens nice because
it's easy to multiply numbers by ten
okay so let me see if I can do this as
simply as I can to show you how this is
gonna work I've got this and this and
this I'm gonna multiply 4 by 10 okay now
quick question for you if I said you
know say I just want to think about 1/5
for a second if I want to multiply it by
10 I've got three alternatives and I
want you to tell me don't shout out to
share let me write them all that you
told me which one is right and why okay
I could multiply the top and bottom by
10 like this okay yes what alternative I
could multiply adjust the top or I could
multiply just the bottom okay so I try
to ask which one of these cuz they're
all different right which one of these
is the real multiply by 10 okay
whoo now I think it'll become clear if
we simplify these
and let's think about let's figure out
this one what's this one gonna be equal
to what could you know I can't in 750 or
we'll just cancel 1000 it's a super fun
so hold on
so doing this what's gonna top the
bottom do the work just came back to say
Baba
hi this 1000 five that's okay try this
one whatever five times five times now
is this is this bigger or smaller than
1/5 if I take 1 then I divide up into
five slices and give you right or if I
take 1 and divided up into 50 slices
you're gonna get very small slices
private more than all of you
so this is locating begone liked it
expense it's getting smaller so this is
not it and this is not its this so when
I multiply by 10 I just wanted multiply
it by the top I keep that eclair when I
go over here okay I'm gonna multiply all
three of these by 10
he's the way I'm going to do it okay I'm
really gonna look at the top that
becomes 20 the 2 turns into a 20 right
all over 5 so that's a really messy 3
okay see what I did you see how this is
similar what we did with it
I've multiplied this by 10 I just look
at the numerator I'll do it again 6
times 10 okay uh-huh
one more tip just just the d-brane out
10 over 2 which is fine okay now look
when I multiply by 10 precisely because
it was the lowest common multiple right
it's gonna cancel
everything's gonna cancel 20 divided by
5 20 divided by 5
alright 60/30 okay good so all of my
fractions are gone now right I've got
full lots of this guy I've got negative
30
lots of this guy and then I just have
this five hang it out this side okay but
this is just like all the other
questions we looked at without fractions
what God refreshes got rid of them now
we just expand shall we do it together 4
times 16 X 4 times 4 okay 4 times 3 well
okay now watch out for the side is too
tricky - 30 times ok now what now what
collect like terms yes then the x's 16x
minus 30 minus 14x 12 plus 6
I love this equation